Game of Thrones is one of the most
densest and most complicated shows on
television and each episode is
multi-layered and loaded with meaning as
the show moves towards this epic
conclusion he has a look at some of the
most important lines from the final
season and in case it's not already
obvious major spoilers ahead so please
proceed with caution when Emilia
Clarke's Daenerys and kit harington's
Jon Snow finally arrived at Winterfell
they meet the rest of the Starks and
tried to convince the northerners to
join their cause
early on Jon mutter something important
to Daenerys northerners don't watch
trust outsiders
Daenerys doesn't exactly impress either
of the stark sisters especially no Sansa
portrayed by actress topi Turner
as you can see why that pronounced
side-eye she clearly doesn't trust this
foreign queen despite John's ringing
endorsement this isn't a good sign for
the Narus but it might not bode
particularly well for Jon either as
viewers know he isn't actually the
illegitimate son of Ned Stark at all
he's the son of the Anna stock in the
neuroses brother Rhaegar Targaryen this
fact gives him the biggest claim to the
Iron Throne
once the North discovers Jon's true
parentage it's entirely possible that
they'll abandon him despite his utter
devotion to protect in the north he's
also uh turley devoted to the queen of
dragons perhaps they'll see that John
who was actually born as Aegon Targaryen
is ultimately an outsider the reunion
between Maisie Williams Arya Stark and
Jon Snow was a highly anticipated moment
after all John gave Arya her very first
sword though their time together in the
first season was entirely too brief it
was clear that they shared an intense
bond when they meet again at the
godswood at Winterfell a provides one of
the show's biggest and most satisfying
emotional moments it even manages to get
a rest smile out of Arya it was hardened
considerably over the course of Game of
Thrones
once the to broach the subject of Sansa
and I clear distrust of Daenerys Arya
defense a sister much to John's surprise
standing her ground
Arya sails of a big sister I'm defending
our family so is she
of course she has absolutely no idea
that the man standing in front of her
isn't part of our media family
he said nicly a Targaryen not a Stark
when John finally shares the truth of
his lineage with Arya and Sansa a year
immediately agrees to honor his requests
and keep the big news a secret but
acting on her distrust of Daenerys Sansa
soon shares a revelation with Tyrion
knowing full well that doing so will
most definitely set off a chain of
events that could ultimately prove quite
problematic for the mother of dragons
fans have been waiting to see what's
going on with Jon and Daenerys ever
since their first trace at the end of
the seventh season well as seen in the
first episode of season a two gave
viewers a sneak peek into their rather
peculiar courtship rituals which include
long romantic dragon rise through the
sky after the two lovebirds finally
decide to give their dragons a break
Daenerys spots a nearby cave saying to
John with a smirk we could stay a
thousand years no one would find us
well there's a reason this romantic
scene might have felt a little familiar
to you her comment brings back memories
of Rhodes Leslie's ill-fated character
Ygritte
a Wilding that Jon once fell in love
with have doomed couple had their first
intimate moments in a cave and the
Ygritte also suggested that they stay
there forever now that people are
starting to learn that the Narus is
actually John's aren't they romantic
relationship is probably just as doomed
as someone between Ygritte and Jon maybe
John should start listening to his
lovers particularly when they suggest
laying low in caves bran stark has been
a total weirdo ever since he took up the
mantle of the three-eyed Raven he spend
the season 8 premiere lurking all over
Winterfell and saying all sorts of
cryptic things one night he has an
encounter with some tally portrayed by
John Bradley when Sam asks what bran is
up to he receives this response waiting
for an old friend at the end of the
episode brands in the courtyard to
witness the arrival of Jamie Lannister
the last time Jamie saw bran he shoved
him out of a high window after bran
court jaime and cersei in a rather
compromising position but the old friend
bran is waiting for it turns out to be
Theon who finally makes his way back to
Winterfell driven by a need to redeem
himself
Theon volunteers to lead the team that
protects bran from the night king during
the climactic battle with the White
Walkers sea an ultimately gives us life
to try and protect as one time foster
brother completing his Redemption arc
and following another line with huge
importance you're a good man
when Jon Snow returns to the north of
daenerys targaryen in tow he's met with
plenty of disapproval one of the loudest
voices is out of Leon a moment the
diminutive butter flavor of house
moments when the northern Nobles inside
the Hall of Winterfell are confused as
to whether they should refer to John or
Daenerys as your grace Leanna stands up
and tells John you left Winterfell a
king and came back
I'm not sure what you weren't out
unbeknownst to Liana it's a rather
pointed statement considering that his
true parentage has been revealed to the
audience and other characters are about
to start learning the news too
really he's still your grace except that
he's not just the rightful king in the
north
he's the king of the Seven Kingdoms in
an effort to bond with John's family
Daenerys pays a visit to Sansa during
the season second episode she asked if
the two can speak alone the dragon
Queens time at the stark family home has
been fairly fraught thus far and Sansa
has been skeptical of this southern
newcomer frustrated by her relationship
with John and highly distrustful of her
during their first private meeting
Daenerys seems to charm sons are quite a
bit telling her that she's travelled all
this way because of her love for John
she reveals her softer more vulnerable
side to Sansa and Sansa does seem to
warm up if only for the moment at one
point in that conversation Sansa says
men do stupid things for women she's
referring to John letting Daenerys take
control of the north but her words could
practically be a thesis statement on one
of Game of Thrones underlying themes
from the attempted murder of Brant
little fingers many schemes and John's
dangerous plan to capture a lone white
so many misfortunes of befallen men as
they attempted to impress women this one
sentence succinctly sums up one of the
show's central concerns on the eve of
the epic Battle of Winterfell most of
the characters gather up for one final
night together they consider their own
mortality sing drink and try to satisfy
their every desire
just in case the army of the Dead
overtakes him before dawn during a
discussion by the fire some Tarly chimes
in saying that the loss of memories is
the worst fate of all and telling his
comrades death isn't okay some cells as
friends are they all might die leaving
their names and legacies lost a time it
becomes clear that some is determined to
keep the memories of his loved ones
alive no matter what happens during the
coming battle this all fits in quite
nicely with one of the most popular
theories about Sam thanks to his
education at the Citadel many people
believe the series concludes with him
writing the titular Song of Ice and Fire
he might be destined to transcribe all
the heroic acts of the people around him
to their feats can live on forever after
his speech it seems even more likely
that Sun will be the chronicler of the
entire game of Thrones story since he's
not a strong fighter or contender for
the throne
it seems like historian is a perfect
role for him to play as a saga thunders
towards its finale he is hoping he's a
faster writer than george RR martin the
Battle of Winterfell takes place at the
ancestral home of the Starks
so is there wonder that the family is
front and center while Sansa is stuck
down in the crypts a sister Arya is out
there fighting for her life since they
were united in season seven that the
sisters have been working together to
hold the north and protect the stark
family now that they've reached
adulthood they seem to have arrived at a
place of mutual respect and love this
becomes clear when Sun Solomon says she
can't be all together help for drawing
the long nights perhaps she even feels a
bit jealous of a boulder brush a sister
when Aria gives her sister a dragonglass
dagger she tells her to take away the
point yet sound familiar
back in season one John gave a small
sword to Arya and offered her the exact
same instructions he's taken with the
pointy end perhaps Arya is subtly
suggesting to son so that she believes
her both equally formidable warriors
Melisandre came out of the woodwork just
before the Battle of Winterfell began
she wasted no time shoving off lighting
the weapons of every Dothraki warrior on
the front lines are pretty cool flex if
you ask us however she had plenty more
to do join this battle and it's all tied
to Arya Stark
after several horrifying and grueling
run-ins with whites Arya finds a brief
moment of safety alongside the Hound and
Melisandre in a locked chamber in
Winterfell for the first time in years
Arya seems just about ready to throw in
the towel
luckily Melisandre reminds her of a
prophecy she made in season 3 during
their first meeting I see a darkness in
you
and in that darkness eyes staring back
at me brown eyes green eyes and blue
eyes
Melisandre pauses before blue eyes to
suggest that Arya is the one who will
ultimately take down not only the night
king but all of his blue-eyed brethren
arias tryst with Gendry raised plenty of
eyebrows but it was a serious thrill
getting to watch arya pursue the object
of her desire and the night clearly
meant a lot to Gendry after the Battle
of Winterfell with an heiress named
Gendry the Lord of storms end Gendry
immediately finds our year and tells her
that he loves her asking for her hand in
marriage any game of Thrones fan who's
been paying attention to re a story
knows exactly how this moment will play
out even though she clearly cares about
Gentry she turns him down immediately
I'm not lady I never have been that's
not me this is a subtle callback to a
moment she shared in season one with Ned
after her father suggests she might one
day become the lady of a great castle
That's not me re Arras undergone quite a
remarkable transformation throughout the
course of the show but she still knows
who she is and who she isn't Sansa
Starks evolution on Game of Thrones has
seen her grow from a whiny preteen to a
consummate survivor and shrewd
strategist characters within the show of
noticed her incredible growth just as
much as audiences have during the
celebrations at Winterfell in the fourth
episode of the eighth season
Sansa reunites with the Hound who
referenced says he abuse she suffered at
the hands of her late husband Ramsay
Bolton a sadistic madman who brutalized
her within an inch of her life when she
tells the hound as she dispatched her
Ramsay with hounds the warrior lets out
an impressed chuckle and tells her
you've changed little bird he tells
Sansa that if she'd left King's Landing
under his protection she never would
have had to deal with these horrible men
and such awful circumstances as Sansa is
a perfect line of reasoning prepared
Littlefinger and Ramsay in the rest I
would have stayed a little burden while
I she makes it perfectly clear that this
little bird isn't so little anymore and
can fly just as well as anyone or
anything check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Game of Thrones are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]